Danish sounds odd,
like a throat condition,
like Danes are holding back a cough or
maybe they got a potato stuck in their
throats. Apparently. At least
that's what everyone's telling me.
But why?
Why does Danish sounds so funny to people?
I recently explored how Swedes,
Norwegians and Danes can all communicate
without having to switch languages.
But this wasn't fair and
even some languages were more
intelligible than others.
The Internet eagerly pointed his
finger at one language in particular.
Danish did it. I posted a video and I'm
told that Danish is a throat condition.
I log into social media and I read
about the potato in their throat.
I go visit a discussion board
and it's a strangled goose.
A study tells me Swedish kids here Danish
as uglier and stranger than Danes do
Swedish. The sure some of this is
banter and good natured teasing,
but even taking it all with
a grain of salt, he herring.
I still have to ask what
makes Danish sounds so funny.
Maybe I could just add my own theory.
I'll blame it on too much Danish
butter in there. Crigler but no,
this is native Lang. So you already
know what we're about to do.
Sift through the history of Danish to
uncover what specifically about its
pronunciation makes it stand out.
Now,
Danish is notoriously hard to learn
to pronounce. You'll hear me try,
but somebody please back me up.
It may feel
okay.
Travel back in time.
Once upon a 1300 years ago,
Denmark was speaking in Indo European
dramatic language with a unique northern
flavor, which we call old Norse. To them,
it's the [inaudible] Tonga,
the Dane tongue throughout Scandinavia.
This is a time of unity.
Everywhere you go,
Norse sounds like Norse,
but soon these Dame Tanger's grow restless
and get upgraded to Viking status in
the Viking age. Something we'll
change. It starts in Denmark,
uh, Dane, probably many Danes,
but definitely this one decides I'm going
to start seeing my vols differently,
which leads east Norse to
split away from West Norse.
It's the start of a trend, the perfect
setup for the rest of our story.
Hey everybody.
Uh,
there was another sound change in
Denmark and at this point over a thousand
years ago, we can officially
call it Denmark, the Dane March.
See this rune stone says,
so the vikings settled down the
Middle Ages settle in at this point,
Scandinavia is a continuum of dialects
that smoothly trace their origins to east
and west.
Norse.
Oh and the too often forgotten old
goodness on its own island were valid
sometimes didn't agree with
either Norse West or east.
Officially though this is an era of Latin,
not too much written Norse until Denmark
decides to go medieval and ink this
scanning and law thanks to scribal
copying this law was available in multiple
versions,
including this awesome one in ruins.
It's words show off another Danish change
unstressed vowels are getting weaker.
This is how you're nicely distinguished
endings in Swedish and Norwegian.
We'll all end up in
Danish with uh, uh, uh,
meanwhile the Hanseatic league is
uniting to dominate the continents and
Northern Coast,
which brings a war and
many new words from middle,
low German or Middle Nether Dutch.
Also.
Meanwhile,
another change is happening in Denmark.
Consonants becoming softer,
like how to soften to Ah,
in math too.
Math,
this is Lynn [inaudible]. It's a
normal change. Just ask Spanish,
but weirdly Danes do it.
At the end of syllables,
consonants and unstressed.
Vowels are weakening,
but stressed vowels are
multiplying by count Danish,
we'll end up with more distinct vowels
than maybe any other language. Now,
this is a Danish that's getting different.
We're a Honda something,
but on the sounds funny scale so far,
I'd rate it a chuckle.
So far.
It's 1526 a Swede writes that Dane
sound like they want to cough,
turning words in their throats.
Arriving in ringing.
What is this?
Throatiness we won't know for another
two centuries before a Danish grow.
Marian rights in the [inaudible] squint.
Hey,
at least my Latin works.
Also bolt title. Well,
this book describes how Danes pronounced
many syllables with a very little
hiccup,
a little hiccup with a bold name.
A punch shock or blast is a stove.
This punch to the throat isn't one sound.
It's sums up an entire process,
a complicated process with multiple
phases and a bunch of anatomy happening in
your throat.
It's not on every syllable either.
These don't have it.
These ones do.
So yeah,
it's been called creaky cough like,
and let's not forget a constant
stream of tiny hiccups.
And it is crucial if you ever went to
master that genuine Danish accent at the
very moment,
this author's writing about hiccups.
There's another sound change in Denmark
this time for once though it's not
danishes fault.
Danish preserved a trilled Norse,
but now throughout France and Germany,
a new ar is spreading a
dramatic worth its own story.
The so called guttural, ah, instead
of a front of the tongue trill,
it's a back of the mouth.
Ahh,
Denmark cut a bad case of this bug whose
symptoms include turning words like as
into this
third results isn't even
throw to your Danish.
We're almost there almost because they
have all the rights sounds in Copenhagen,
but Scandinavia is still a
rich tapestry of dialects.
Sweden will keep its many variants,
including a Swedish side form of goodness.
In Norway.
There's still no single spoken Norwegian,
but back in Denmark,
the old dialects,
some of which never even had that
stood will witness one last change.
Traditional dialects.
We'll mostly vanish.
We end up with nearly all of
Denmark speaking one language,
a language with the simplest
grammatical endings in Scandinavia.
We can consonants perhaps the largest
number of vowels in the world and little
hiccups in [inaudible],
and that is how the Danes went from
speaking north just as well as anybody to
sounding amazingly on harp,
oddly amazing.
Stick around and subscribe for language.